let's jump over to the social components
here because we got some funny stuff to
talk about in this reddit post from two
x chromosomes which is transphobic by
the way very transphobic they write just
cancelled a first date this week because
i can't emotionally handle more men in
my life after all of this after the
scotus news the idea of having to laugh
at some dude's jokes and listen to him
ramble on about his life and possibly
kiss and have sex with him knowing he
has all the rights in the world and i
don't i just can't i don't have the
emotional energy to even fake a smile i
don't know when i will this was one of
the highest rated posts on the two x
chromosomes
uh
subreddit
and um you know this is some kind of
borderline or that's insane
well actually let's ask the both of the
ladies in the room do you ever feel like
guys are walking around like i have all
of these right side i laugh at you yeah
and you're a subject agent what is this
do you do you ever feel this way as
women that men are walking around going
i just don't understand how the man has
the right to have an abortion when men
don't get pregnant well hold on wait
wait men but hold on i was told men can
get pregnant that's true
this is really interesting two x
chromosomes has a pride flag right here
in there in the subreddit you can see
you pull it up
so uh you can see right here they have
the pride flag as like part of the
colors
but they're saying more men in my life
have all the rights but what about a
pregnant man a pregnant man would not
have the right to an abortion by their
logic and standards
i don't think they have any logic no i
think it is just it's like it's it's you
know what i call it's fire it's chaotic
it expands
it's in and then it consumes
this makes fear propaganda that just is
making people crazy like i genuinely
just
i i don't feel this strongly about it
because i don't feel that pregnancy
would be the absolute worst thing that
could ever happen to me that would end
my life and so i need to like have this
much fear that controls me about it if
you hear
that states you don't live in
may restrict abortion in a few months
and then you look at some random man and
you're like i just can't you you and
your rights
get out of my sight it's just
you're not you're you've lost it yeah
completely something is wrong it's
absurd well it's also again men it's not
as if men have the right to go i mean i
guess the male abortion doctors do but i
think you know they should be stripped
of that right as well and not now they
don't right once abortion is illegal so
i have no idea what you're talking about
can we give a collective shout out to
all of the women who do this every time
they say it's time to stop having sex
with men and that's just like strata
that's the play but they're thinking
they they think that it's like some
punishment and all the conservatives are
like based yeah i know it's like you
know what you know what because of these
far-right conservatives i'm just i'm not
gonna have sex with a man until her
values are similar enough to have a
child together and he commits to me for
life and it's like this yeah that's good
this was actually a post i saw it was a
woman saying ladies it's time for a sex
strike and it was like explain to the
men that it's too risky now that because
they could get pregnant and that means
having a baby they can't risk having sex
with a man and it's just like that's the
conservative argument like you're
literally making the conservative
argument for like
not having sex out of wedlock i think
but what you're ignoring tim is they're
actually talking about creating this
institution where the woman only has sex
with one man she trusts to raise a child
with her in case she does get pregnant
and they're not allowed to leave each
other so i think that's like a new
original interesting idea yo you know it
was one of the craziest things i was
reading about that there were lesbians
who became straight during coveted
lockdown
did you you don't see those stories
there was one it was like i think maybe
vice published it where it was a woman
she was like i'm a lesbian but i was
quarantined with my roommate who's male
and we started dating and like hooking
up and then she was like she changed
like something
well it i don't know and the same it's
interesting because the same way that we
are not allowed to acknowledge the
existence of d transitioners such as
yourself you're also not allowed to
acknowledge the existence of people who
no longer identify as homosexual
i think you guys this is it from slate
yeah my identity is less important than
my intimacy yes it's from april 10th
2020. a quarantine fling with my
roommate has me questioning my sexuality
so i think this was uh
yeah it's like running her hands through
his chest hair
she hasn't hooked up with a man in three
years but then she got locked down with
him and her identity didn't matter
anymore and i'm like it's a confusing
article to me because sexual and
identity are different to these people i
didn't i didn't know that
i don't know how much that is like an
actual lesbian turning straight because
of the pandemic and how much of it is
just like the queer ideology about what
a lesbian actually is like i think that
there's a lot of people who are involved
in these communities and they call
themselves gay or they call themselves a
lesbian but it's like they're thinking
of it more from like a gender identity
perspective as opposed to like actually
growing up being like a homosexual
person that's interesting so i would ask
you is someone who did detransition do
you uh like reject the idea of
transgenderism altogether or do you just
believe that was something that didn't
work for you
um yeah i reject the whole category of
trans trans people i don't think that
that's a meaningful
cat because it's like can we get a
definition of that please what is a
trans person and how is that different
from a person who identifies as trans
and then no longer identifies as trans
yeah and that's a very good point and
not only do they not have a definition
for that but they've dispensed with
important definitions for things like
woman or man so it like causes the
system to become incoherent but i'm
curious as someone who you know spent
you said five years as transgender what
what made you see
that this was not well legitimate from
the beginning
how did how did you come to
be trans and then how did you come to
not be
yeah so it wasn't like i just woke up
one day and went from being
myself to wanting to be a boy um so
growing up i never i wasn't like super
masculine or anything i was never even
really like a tomboy i feel like i had
like a good even mix of like girl
typical boy typical interests and stuff
um so it really started for me when i
started using the internet a lot
for me it was tumblr that i started
using the most and on tumblr
there is a strong emphasis on like
social justice ideology and so in order
to participate in those communities you
have to adopt a lot of those beliefs so
i kind of adopted those like radical
progressive beliefs about gender and and
race and everything honestly um and in
that environment it's it's highly
encouraged to like experiment with your
gender identity like you see all of
these
messages that are just like oh well if
you don't like your body that's a sign
that you're trans or if you
read certain kinds of fan fiction that's
a sign that you're trans and you should
change your pronouns you should cut your
hair and just see how it feels and then
every time you do that you cut your hair
to see how it feels or you change your
pronouns then everybody comes and like
lavishes positive attention on you so i
think it was like
yeah yeah but it's for me in my case i
know that there are legitimate cases of
grooming where adults actually i mean
there are trans activists who brag about
how many minors they've sent hormones to
through the mail um so that that
definitely is a thing that happens but
for me it was mostly like just other
teenagers who were going through i don't
know loneliness depression
um eating disorders are also really
common who are just kind of all latching
on to this idea that they're born in the
wrong body or they're they're meant to
be someone else and they can just
discover that and then they can bring
that into the real world that must feel
very difficult you know to think that
you are not actually yourself or you are
not actually the person whose body that
you occupy
um i would say it's very easy for
someone who's disconnected from reality
and doesn't have a lot of ties to like
the real physical world like for context
in my adolescence i was one of those
kids who like i didn't really play any
sports i didn't have a lot of friends in
real life i mainly just kind of was
online doing creative things like
writing and doing art and talking to
other people online so i think it's easy
to get lost in
like especially as a creative person you
can get lost in these ideas about who
you are and what you can become well i i
just want to clarify by difficult i
don't necessarily mean um it's it's
difficult to pull off or do i'm saying
it it sounds like it would be painful
though to to feel as though you had not
matched what you were meant to be it's
possible i'm off base here yeah i think
the feelings that brought me to search
for that were painful so i was like i
had a ton of self-esteem issues i had
depression um and all this kind of stuff
so that was incredibly painful but the
idea that
you know the source of all that pain was
that i was meant to be another gender
and that i can
transition and it'll fix everything that
wasn't painful interesting
can i just ask you mentioned i just got
asked that you mentioned fan fictions
what were people saying that fan fiction
said about your gender identity
yes so um
one thing on tumblr that is
very very popular it's not fringe at all
it's very popular is like male male fan
fiction it's like gay fan fiction
um and so people will say that oh if
you're a girl and you read gay fan
fiction that is like the number one sign
that you're actually a boy inside
yeah how old were you when you first got
into the um tumblr 13 13. and so how did
you come to
change and move away from all of that so
it actually took bringing that into the
real world by you know actually
trying to look like a boy and like act
like a boy and be in like male spaces
using the men's restroom i actually did
that um
it was just like holy crap like this is
not
right for me at all
you were taking testosterone for a year
and a half yeah i was taking
testosterone for a year and a half and
another
part of it that made me really
regret it and realized that it was a
mistake is the fact that the
testosterone had extremely negative
effects on me like what um so for me it
was mostly psychological i wasn't on it
for long enough for it to have like any
long-term physical effects but um
just it really destabilized me and
another piece of context is that the
people who prescribed me it prescribed
me four times the dosage that i should
have started on
um and that's a whole other story we can
get into if you want
yeah yeah um
so basically i i got my testosterone
from planned parenthood and it was just
one appointment i walk in um they talk
to me for like 20 minutes and then i sit
down with a nurse practitioner and she
says okay we're going to start you on
like 25 milligrams and then i say to her
well i think that i need more because my
hips are big so i think i have extra
estrogen and i'm gonna need more
testosterone to look like a boy and she
did not push back on that whatsoever and
she just asked me like okay well how
high would you like to go and then i
said what's the highest we can do and
she said okay we'll start you on 100
milligrams and then wow yeah i just got
sent out to parenthood mm-hmm
interesting bad people it turns out yeah
was it like physical any physical nausea
or anything
um no
did you want to fight people yes that
was the thing like i literally was just
completely transformed into like a
different person like um the way i
describe it is like
my
i stopped having a wide spectrum of
emotion and instead of like okay
something happens and it makes me feel
abandoned so that i'm nervous so then
i'm sad so then i cry
i would just go straight from like point
a to point i'm gonna anger now you know
punch somebody a
and you're like working in the backyard
and you're like trying to hammer a nail
and then you hit the nail and the nail
drops you get angry
yes you're skateboarding trying to do a
trick you miss it's angry
and you walk into the kitchen to get a
sandwich there's no more roast beef
and like just punching things that but
imagine you're actually a neurotic 18
year old girl oh you had it all
that's amazing yeah
i remember it's horrible there was a
simpsons joke about that where ralph or
something was taking no no it was martin
he was like they put me on testosterone
you want to fight
there was uh there's another really good
bit it was a halloween special and
bart's talking to these robots they're
like you're a human what's it like to
have feelings he's like i said i'm a
human not a girl
um helena did were there other chemicals
than testosterone that you or that they
put on you or that you used or anything
oh not that well i was on a bunch of
psych meds also is the other thing um
because the
testosterone very fun it like it the
rage attacks that it sent me into were
so intense that i ended up actually
hurting myself oh man and wow yeah so i
had to be hospitalized twice for these
reasons rage yeah yeah like it was like
totally
nothing that i was ever prepared for i
don't even think it's normal for like
men like i think it was beyond what is
normal uh well i mean people some people
have anger problems i guess yeah but
they put you on
i mean that your body isn't meant for
that stuff right exactly yeah my body's
not meant for it and it was four times
the dose i was supposed to be on i
wonder if the aggressive trans movement
that we're witnessing is part of a
testosterone uptake yes
literally yes it's a bunch of people
with endocrine disorders induced by the
doctors and nurses that they're seeing
to treat their gender dysphoria
so they're getting explain more about a
lot of testosterone and they're getting
aggression because of it a lot of
testosterone and men who are on estrogen
like people's like your brain and your
body is meant to work on the hormones
that you're meant to produce you're not
gonna be a mentally or physically
healthy person if you're taking a bunch
of testosterone as a woman or a bunch of
estrogen and suppressing your
testosterone as a man and isn't it
insane that not only is that a
controversial thing to say nowadays but
that it's it's not even just not common
sensical like people are angry with us
for pointing this out and they're angry
with you for saying hey like i actually
did it it doesn't work so so
i tweeted this
it's strange that if you oppose sex
change surgery for minors you're
considered right-wing
yeah
like hands down and the two responses i
got were people saying
you're a transphobe or
you're a liar that's not happening
and so it seems like there's probably a
lot of people who are aligned themselves
with democrats to the left who don't
realize what is happening both with
chemical intervention and surgical
intervention for minors they don't i
mean a friend of mine he goes by
billboard chris on twitter he does this
thing where he goes out to various
public spaces and he has conversations
with people about this trans stuff and
he was talking to this young woman about
how kids are being sterilized which is
what happens if a child is put on
puberty blockers and then cross-sex
hormones they will be sterilized that's
not devastating
hormones across sex hormones
that's not debatable they will be
infertile they will be sterilized and
this young woman who was so passionately
arguing with him she
refused to believe that children were
being sterilized she was like that's not
happening that's not happening it's like
no that's happening to thousands of
children
it's new technology i think what you're
saying it's important that we have the
conversation it might people may get
angry about stuff in general but it's
such a new technology it's important
that we open up the debate thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you